foreign
Patrick is with us in Tucson Arizona hi
Patrick how are you
I'm great how are you today better than
I deserve what's up
hey so I just had a quick question here
I was going through some of your older
Dave Ranson uh on YouTube and heard one
about gold and I agree with you that
mutual funds are definitely a better
investment in the long term than gold I
also agree that people would not be
trading gold bars for blue jeans or
whatever in the event of a major
economic collapse but
um where I would kind of challenge a bit
is as far as gold goes I would look at
it more as like an insurance policy to
kind of preserve the wealth in the event
of some sort of major economic situation
if you had some of your wealth in Gold
then presumably if there was some sort
of collapse of a currency and a new
currency were to come up that wealth
would maintain its value at least
somewhat through the transition and uh
and then when you out at the other side
you'd still have you know you wouldn't
have lost everything right
[Music]
the problem is that since the Roman
Empire you can't find an example of that
happening
of of people using gold to preserve to
survive an economic collapse and it
holds its value and they come back and
turn a corner on a currency it never has
happened
well I mean if we look at
um I know in in your previous uh you
know rant on on gold you had mentioned
the uh um the the Confederacy right and
if you know
um at that time people did use gold as
currency and anybody who had gold as
currency
um and if they kept that instead of
transitioning to the Confederate money
um then once that Confederate dollars
collapse they still have that value in
the gold same thing with you know the
economic collapse in um uh in Germany in
the 1920s and and you know and so on
well I mean you can convert to assets of
all kinds of things in the event of an
economic collapse uh that will write it
out uh
you know
that I I think the thing you've got to
think about here is
where can you find what you're talking
about actually being used
by wealthy people people that have built
wealth
to cause them to hold on to wealth and
to grow wealth you just can't find it
Patrick
um and you're spending too much time on
the internet
um yeah Patrick what are your worries
gonna happen
I mean I I'm I'm somewhat of a prepper
myself so I'm not worried so to speak
that everything is going to collapse
tomorrow but I think when you look at a
long enough time frame for for your
theory to work in your lifetime the U.S
dollar would have to completely have had
no value like Confederate money did
or like Iranian money did under Saddam
Hussein you would have to have the US
dollar the largest economy in the
history of the world become worth
nothing for your theory to work
and I'm sorry I'm not buying it
so would there be something else that
you would say is a is a better thing to
um to to look at to protect yourself
from a um from a financial I'm not
planning for the Apocalypse
I don't do financial planning for the
apocalypse I don't have anything for the
apocalypse the best thing I've got for
Apocalypse is several thousand rounds
but um uh so I'll be eating but other
than that I'm not you know I'm not
planning for the apocalypse I'm not
doing financial planning for the
apocalypse I'm not predicting the end of
time and I'm not going to predict my my
life as if everything as We Know It in
America today becomes valueless
I'm not going to set my mind on that
track I'm not going to set my friends on
that track and I'm not going to set you
on that track if you want to get on that
track Patrick you can find a way to
rationalize all that negativity if you
want but I'm I just don't believe it
and and I and I think it leads you to
ridiculous places to put money
uh and so I buy real estate and I buy
mutual funds so you know you don't have
to agree with me uh you get you a show
and you talk about gold that'll be great
but I'm not doing it I'm not going to
suggest you do it right well and one of
the best ways to prepare for financial
collabs if you're thinking that might be
a thing is to walk through the baby
steps and actually become wealthy I've
talked to different point is all that
wealth would disappear right but here's
the thing I have talked to Preppers
before who are still in debt
that's a problem like that is actually
well that's believing more in the
collapse than it is in the non-collapse
right because in the non-collapse you
would want to get rid of the debt but in
a collapse that would be a great thing
because you got you never paid it back
and you're counting on the end of time I
mean this is like
um you know it's a it's a theological
doctrinal problem as well as a uh just a
philosophy of life and so you know I I'm
not a prepper not mad at you if you're a
prepper uh but I'm not a prepper I'm not
predicting the end of Life as We Know It
While I'm Alive
um and so I'm not going to say that the
US dollar is going to become worth
absolutely the same thing as the Iranian
dollar with Saddam Hussein's face on it
which is absolutely paper money or
Monopoly money or Confederate money or
any other collapsed economy in former
currencies you would have for this idea
to work you would have to assume the US
dollar is going to do that and I just
think that that's an asinine set of
assumptions
I mean it's just there's nothing that
indicates that but even if you are a
prepper get out of debt start there like
if you're really trying to be prepared
for some Financial collapse like
Financial collapse probably wouldn't
happen overnight anyways it could drag
out for 10 or 20 years so it's like even
if you think that's gonna happen get out
of debt pay off your house build wealth
that'll help you be prepared for
anything I own real estate a lot of it
and so uh but guess what in a financial
collapse a Communist Regime comes in
takes over all private property
potentially so that can be taken away oh
by the way they could come take your
gold bars too
because they just decided to they come
take your farm
they shoot people
and take their stuff
this is how Russia was formed hello I
mean the Bolsheviks the the gulags I
mean that they went and killed the
farmers and took their Farms
uh that's what communism does so if you
how do you protect gold bars aren't
going to protect you from that you know
and neither is debt-free and nothing you
know so I'm just not going to financial
plan for the apocalypse I'm not going to
do it uh if you want to you can
but you're you know
that shirt you can do a lot of stupid
stuff if you want to but it's loud out
there but it's not what we're going to
teach you to do well and it's living in
that world of fear like it's living in
that space of everything is bad the
world is going bad and it's like when
you're in that space of no I will tell
you one thing he did get me on one thing
that he's exactly right on that if you
took your Confederate money and you
converted it to Gold Bars before the
Confederacy collapsed
the gold was worth something after that
and the Confederate money wasn't
and he's right I did I I was wrong about
that
so it did it did cause you to survive
the collapsed economy because you could
have took the gold and sold it for
Northern dollars right called US Dollars
now and you know you would have
converted your wealth and not lost your
wealth so he is actually right about
that but you for for him to be right
though to do this you would have to
assume the collapse of the dollar like
the Confederate dollar become worth
nothing and I'm just I'm just not gonna
set my life up on that hinge if you want
to it's okay I'm not really not mad at
you
um I just think you're wrong and you
think I'm wrong so there you go so go do
what you want to do that's how it works
that's okay it's okay it's fine that's
fine I you know uh if the US dollar
collapses I'm wrong